okay who is this guy new Monty no new
Monty know spanish GM net never played
him so let's see what we get no open
Sicilian aha okay I wanted to play the
Kalashnikov I can try this somewhat
obscure move order okay it tries to
prevent it or wrong wrong good it tries
to make use of my my we add new water
sorry this is not really a good good
line for black I was gambling there a
little bit let's see what is doing mmm
right okay it should be still still from
somewhat playable it's the same
structure as in many other so
accessories with e 5 and d6 where you
have this whole on d5 you want some
dynamic compensation for it one issue is
that the move Knight f6 here is probably
answered by Bishop to g5 which is a bit
annoying but well I don't know if I want
to play g6 yeah of course he's doing
that but as mentioned I I wasn't sure
after Bishop takes Queen takes at least
the night sm attacked and night d6
should give me really good compensation
it usually gives black good compensation
this kind of porn snatch or I mean most
of the times in the usual line that give
gives black more than enough
compensation okay yeah i'm just going to
go back and see what what happens it
still might lead to a pretty pretty
normal sveshnikov structure
hmm so is angling form for h5 maybe hmm
yeah they came to a g6 h5 this kind of
thing it's not so clear how I develop if
I don't do that so probably I have to
and Bishop 86 is also also a possibility
yeah oh yeah exactly the right moment
gentlemen when Queen d7 is not possible
and I could move ok my hope is to trade
am Bishop from age 6 but probably he
will play night c4 probably
I take now see ya okay I have to get rid
of this the dark scratch dark squared
bishop is at a tube too bad oh this was
the idea that's an interesting concept
ok Knight f6 now is not a leading what
really i was say what did to say that's
not leading to anything he's still doing
that ok the drill that looks strange
really what is the point you want to
play g4 I don't know I thought this
should be really ok here and Queen two
is six months thats it's just ok for
black unless i'm overlooking something
drastic
I had it's okay for me however I'm also
having an eye on the h2porn so long
castles I can consider to take it
probably I won't because there are ideas
like night I'd night h5 for example in
any case I really don't want to take I
can and what I'm playing I think isn't
it is totally ok ok Rangoon ig8 if he
can go back I see
let's prepare that 95 f5s is the idea ok
so i now can take and I guess I will
I don't ever expect any office moves
this is this is interesting now I can go
here which is basically blocking any g4
move Queen f6 is not threatening that
much it's just it's basically just a
check a check to say check but not not
much else yeah but this isn't this a
pretty pretty okay endgame or structure
is fine and if five
mmm you for that gives me some problems
or not can also set this in motion let's
do that
my idea is to go Luke h8 now using the H
file now yes c5 at the end but still
that don't get anything in this game
absolutely no move check so f 44 the
pawn or am i able to play I can also do
this try to go to the D file and first
grabbing this point so that I have two
connected passes
I think I'm just winning I really don't
see how we defense this check
okay that's not the ideal pawn structure
but still want to go to d3 and I could I
could have played rookie for actually
time okay i know the dough i take this
first check check white forfeits on time
mmm yeah i don't know i didn't expect
most of the museum I thought that I'm
I'm okay in this position maybe i'm not
but i thought i'm ok it's not clear to
me how we improve some its position
maybe still some form of g4 but I really
don't know that this this looks fairly
normal to me this what I mean I don't
really see is very forward if he is some
I mean that 95 I think it's probably not
the solution maybe if you just pile up
my move would be probably 98 getting rid
of this and after here I thought that f5
becomes an idea yeah fighting against
the night and I thought that should be
equal about equal going back and this is
this end game I thought this is probably
still equal but if anybody I can do
something I thought but maybe this is
just my morong founded optimism yeah
with f5 and so on I mean the computer
gives me a slight edge but when it got
serious when he when he played this kind
of thing here here this is now winning
for black straight away
so we cannot do that I thought he should
take and play this and I don't know does
this should be okay for white he's got
this this good deep on something along
these lines I mean it would be very
reactive why doesn't trouble with the
deep horn it is very likely it will be
will be some kind of draw but in the
games I gave me he gave me this and she
I think like like just like Chad Winns
really so too many pawns okay well
thanks for watching